congratulations you just beat resident
evil 7 the credits are rolling and other
than trying the game in VR after seeing
a video about it on the Internet
you've experienced all there is to the
game right wrong because you've just
unlocked madhouse difficulty and it's
much more than just a difficulty bump it
changes the game and plays with your
expectations in some pretty cool ways I
can't resist a premise like that so
let's find out how different madhouse
really is by the way I am going to talk
openly about the first section of the
game up until you leave the main house
so if you don't want to hear any
spoilers or you want to experience
madhouse blind pause this video
subscribe so you don't forget play the
game and then come back and watch let's
do this
[Music]
the first and most important difference
you'll notice is when you get to your
first save saves and Madhouse are
limited just like in the original
Resident Evil except instead of finding
ink ribbons you appropriately use
cassette tapes you'll always find
several tapes next to every save along
with some scattered around the estate
but even with this relatively generous
supply you're still forced to save more
sparingly than you did in normal mode
Auto saves are less frequent but not
gone completely they will still happen
in certain story moments to save you the
frustration of having to watch
unskipable cutscenesthat's to kill you
and even worse Mia has a much larger
health pool with only 27 bullets every
shot counts a frequently found myself
running out of ammo and having to switch
to the hatchet which against the
chainsaw well
I had to do this fight eight times okay
fine it's a brutal opener but the fight
is important because it teaches you two
things that will help you survive
madhouse
dodging enemies and nailing those
headshots
after the dinner scene you have to avoid
Jack like usual while in normal I could
cheese it and run from Jack hiding
become so much more important due to his
increased damage okay time for the
garage fight just got to pick up the car
key and ha in a devious twist you must
now find a lockpick to open the box that
holds the key in the main hall things
start getting really different there are
now three of those cages that take
antique coins two of them feature new
attack and defense bonuses but the third
has the Scorpion key in it which was
originally in the basement if you have
enough antique coins to unlock the
Scorpion key right away you can use the
key to bypass a shadow puzzle quickly
get to the next safe room and get the
shotgun early but on the other hand you
don't actually need the key to progress
and I wanted to save my coins so let's
go upstairs oh right remember how Jack
shoots himself and then dramatically
reveals he's still alive in the bathroom
that doesn't happen here he shows up
pretty much right away and pursues you
more aggressively
know what screw it let's just let's try
to keep now I shoot okay come on come on
okay just gotta run to the save room in
and there's the next big change enemy
placement has moved and later game
enemies now show up right away
this makes the basement Trek terrifying
all over again as you never know what
will pop up and when fighting the molded
is tough since they now soak up way more
bullets I wasted all of my ammo on just
two of them although this does make
getting that critical headshot all the
more satisfying however the game
actually balances this increased
difficulty out really well as the
basement has fewer enemies and it did on
normal the basement is also where I put
the saving system through its paces I
found that you were given just enough
cassettes to feel like you can waste one
or two if you need to but not so many
that it removes the stress of choosing
to save if you play smart it won't lead
to frustration
you should always save in a new slot
though just in case you need a reload
item placement has changed as well there
are more coins to make up for the extra
cages but their locations are moved
around major items like repair kits and
even some weapons have been moved and
made available earlier basic items like
ammo boxes have fewer bullets and you'll
find far more separating gel instead of
chem fluid this means they'll have to
make tough choices like sacrificing
bullets so you can create medicine and
this is when it clicked for me that
madhouse isn't some brutal difficulty
designed to be punishing and harder but
instead changes up the way you play
Resident Evil 7 enemy encounters are
less frequent but much harder later game
enemies show up earlier but so do
advanced weapons limited saves adds
stress but you can manage that stress by
saving strategically I also understand
now why madhouse is unlocked after you
play through the game once the
foreknowledge of upcoming events like
bosses is important in helping you
decide when to use a safe but at the
same time this knowledge is also use
against you as a game plays with your
expectations in smaller ways like enemy
placement so it can surprise and
you all over again so if you feel the
desire to start playing Resident Evil 7
again like I did give madhouse a try it
does a great job making the experience
feel new again plus beating it unlocks
infinite ammo which makes for some
wonderful catharsis I love talking about
both Resident Evil 7 and games that have
cool alternate modes so if you want to
see more videos like this make sure to
like it and subscribe to our YouTube
channel also if you want to see more
Resident Evil 7 videos I put one out
about what it's like to play the whole
game in VR so check that out thanks for
watching
[Music]